hello and welcome to this video playing
Oh mija mija I don't know yeah I just
don't like the Italian try try try try
something offbeat yeah usually I'm
getting killed then when that's rapid at
cu3
and just one
something unti reticle that is not
you dry
you
[Music]
it looks looks a bit ill to share this
kind of thing but something similar has
been played by some strong players like
reported mamedyarov it's not exactly
this position but this idea and I came
I would like
I would like to treat noids
and I had always had possible it looks
really ordered
it's very daring probably I'm just in
very bad shape but
can you make it more obvious young what
your intention in this game baby I can't
but let's do this
wyndi foreheads probably not it totally
terrible but it just it just feels very
yeah
very much like once you draw okay
and now now no I'm okay at least I'm not
going to be worse in this position
ninety three picks up the bishop am
should I do that yeah
at least
some idea that in the long run
the black sari white still must be fine
what's this f4 really
mm okay I can do this everything else
fails I can do this
you
okay
let's gain some space you never know
where I might meet him
Oh
[Music]
yeah
93 years probably happening next
we okay well white up to this point used
every single opportunity to trade so he
might take only five but I'm more
concerned
93 when it comes to preserving winning
opportunities ok just took it
drew Curtis Ned look f2 right
okay
[Music]
Oh Kim let's take it
here is leading nowhere unfortunately
look f2 was what he definitely wants to
do okay I've got everything on dark
squeeze oh really
No now I get on the second with
with the huge advantage
yeah Roxy to a bishop bishop t1
the only question is do I have anything
better even now
ruk see one ticket
check it is very good I can do that
Luke c10 animove
you
[Music]
otherwise I just a just resigns you know
it's early I mean I think I'm a lot
better of course but you can play cannot
play like here a check and the problem
is a little bit like you cannot go back
and if you go like on the third like
here I'm just taking this one first and
the thing is this is so going this is
also going to be lost if you you cannot
go rupee one yeah something like that is
terrible what is running out of moves
with this bad structure so yeah I played
very risky Lee let's say but somehow it
worked out yeah it was a bit provocative
across this is funny
stock fish is actually suggesting g5 and
disposition and says black a slightly
worse you know first I thought better it
would be funky
okay Queenie seven
the engine rakesh gives d5 that sort of
move that I would be afraid all that
much or I wouldn't be afraid of that all
that much
I mean why this is going to be better
but it's not just like regular for most
regular kings in your position
okay then Knight f6 rupee one g5 so I
know thinking is very conservative
I takes my eggs now pawn takes is
certainly better but again yeah I wanted
to provoke him
I was this was what I was thinking and
then I wanted to go 94 93 Queen f6 but
this is very dangerous of course yeah in
this but he played Queen to deform that
is a lame move for him no yeah no g3 I
was expecting g3 Bishop g7 h3 that was
what I'm thinking get this yeah here now
I'm no I'm okay
you should probably avoid 93 and go to
have one now I got two bishop Pam and
I'm think I'm slightly slightly more
comfortable don't run the bishops may
count for something now okay now he
allowed this and due to the jutsu is
very healthy structure there is just
still nothing terrible has happened yet
here I was expecting Knight takes I
think is a little bit better for me
let's say the engine is actually very
very pessimistic about white
amazing I mean I thought I should be a
bit better because I have the better
pawn structure those are on dark squares
this is annoying and so on but I didn't
expect that the engine would already
display a rather large advantage large
its upon thorn like advantage so um I
was expecting him to play Knight e3 this
I think a better move intending to jump
here and basically stating that the
bishop is in the middle but not so
dangerous at the moment in turn yummy it
there is some likelihood that the knight
will trade against this bishop it's
probably a body home we are now rook t8
and here white is in some trouble
mayor rook t1 is essentially the game
and here yeah I'm definitely for choice
I have the only open file
but King f2 was immensely helpful so
the engine displays rook f2 or something
yeah and it's not much fun I mean why
does simply sitting there and I can do
some expansion
not much fun but again it's it's kind of
solid so I'm not sure that I'm I'm
winning this quickly or anything yeah
rather rather I'm sure I'm not let's say
okay guys thanks for watching